15-inch MacBook gear versus 13-inch
MacBook Air you might think the only
difference is the size but there are
actually a bunch of differences so in
this video we are going to show you guys
all of them including the design
differences the differences in sound
quality because we have a different
speaker system performance and more now
yesterday I put out a video where I took
the new 15 inch apart compared to the 13
inch and we found 10 different internal
differences not all of which make a
difference of actual usability but make
sure you guys check that out it was
quite interesting and today we're going
to compare how these work now starting
out the size difference it sounds like a
little bit but you guys could see the
footprint difference is quite noticeable
it is taller it is wider and the 15 inch
is actually a little bit thicker as well
now what's interesting is the actual
body is the same thickness it is
actually the screen that's a little bit
thicker and apple did that on purpose to
make sure that this thing is still super
high quality and it is rigid it doesn't
Flex at all so they cared about the
engineering both external and on the
inside now as far as the weight I have
to be honest I can tell a difference the
15 inch weighs 3.3 pounds compared to
just 2.7 on the 13 inch but if I'm not
holding him side by side like that this
new 15 inch is incredibly lightweight
I've never felt such a durable quality
laptop feel so light even just holding
it by its corner and just like we told
you guys in our leak videos the ports
are identical the design is identical
the only difference is that the base 15
inch will actually come with a fast
charger or a dual USB type-c charger
instead of a slow one and the crazy
thing is the new 70 watt adapter is
actually quite a bit small than the
previous 67 I'm sure that's one thing
that nobody else has mentioned now
looking at the inside these things look
very similar even actual keyboards are
identical and we were thinking that the
15-inch might have speaker grilles but
it doesn't and it is weird having all
the space without that we have the same
Touch ID the same Notch up above but
it's less noticeable with a larger
screen the bezels look very similar I
know they have a slight difference and
lastly the 15 inch does have a larger
track pad now as far as the displays the
15 inch does have more pixels in the 13
inch but the sharpness and detail is
identical with the 15 inch though you do
have more space on your little bar up
front just because the screen is wider
whereas on the 13 inch we're running out
of room with the same exact icons and
overall you actually get 27 more screen
real estate without 15 inch and that is
a significant difference and now what
I've been waiting for the speaker
comparison because the 15 inch has a new
six-speaker system with really large
enclosures that we saw when we opened it
up compared to tiny little ones on the
13 inch so let's see how big of a
difference that makes
[Music]
wow guys you heard it for yourselves
this is like comparing a cell phone
versus a good tablet yes it is louder
not dramatically so but it's noticeable
but the richness the fullness the extra
depth in the bass the sound is a lot
better and the 13 inch it just got a
little bit embarrassed now the question
is going to be how will this compare to
a 14 inch pro in terms of speaker
quality I love the new Macbook Pros
because of their speaker system for
watching movies and music make sure you
guys are subscribed if you guys want to
see that comparison now both of these
have 1080p webcams this is the 15 inch
that I'm talking on right now and this
this is the 13-inch MacBook Air so you
guys let me know did you notice the
difference in video quality or in terms
of microphone quality down below and now
it's time to get into performance and
the first thing I want to start out is
the ssds when we took it apart we saw
that the 15 inch still has a single land
but let's go ahead and compare it with
our 256 gig base models and as you guys
can see the performance is pretty much
identical if you spend an extra 200
bucks get the 512 you get about double
the performance and that can actually
help for multitasking now as far as CPU
performance both of these ships have the
same exact M2 Chip they have eight
gigabytes of RAM and I'm gonna run the
latest geekbench 6.1 here and here we go
as far as single core uh the 13 inch
beats It Out by four points and
multi-core the 13 inch beats It Out by
just a little bit more now this of
course Within margin of error and this
is geekbench 6.1 so you can't compare it
with the previous older models but the
performance is basically the same now
what could be different is thermal
throttling because of the larger size
and with that our Graphics are also
different so we'll take a look at that
as well and let's start out with
cinebench for throttling I'm going to
run a single test right now just to get
our Baseline and then we'll do the 10
minute stress test okay wow uh just the
one run we actually see a higher score
79.30 on the 15 inch compared to 77.53
on the 13 whereas in geekbench this
thing won that is crazy now let's go
ahead and run that 10 minute throttling
test I have MX power Gadget opened up
right here so we can see everything and
as far as attempt 99 degrees 92 degrees
definitely there's a difference as far
as thermals now the clock speed is also
higher 3.2 compared to 3.1 right there
the wattage is higher so this thing is
staying cooler look at these both of
them are running quite hot pretty much
the same even this one a little higher
but it's still running faster almost
like apple has tuned a little bit
differently it's been eight minutes so I
busted out the thermal Cam and it looks
like on the 13 inch the hottest spots
about 45 degrees
and on the 15 inch we're seeing 43
degrees now comparing the actual Heat
it does seem like it's more spread out
in the chassis on the 15 inch and it's a
little bit cooler on the right hand side
over there the whole machine is running
cooler and as far as actual performance
we are having higher clock speeds and a
higher wattage we have 2.9 compared to
2.6 gigahertz so yes the 15 inch does
perform better but let's see how much of
a difference and check out this dip
right here that shows that the chassis
already heat soaked and we're at 10
watts a little under 11 compared to 14.7
so we're almost done here let's see the
scores here are the scores we have
7509 for the 15 inch and 7082 for the 13
inch so this thing dropped about five
percent performance while this one
dropped about nine and the difference
instead of two percent is now six and if
we were to go even longer the difference
would grow because the wattage here can
drop even more so if you care about
performance of the CPU yes you will
notice a difference in those longer
heavier tasks now let's go ahead and
close this down and take a look at the
graphics because the 15 inch model at
the base price actually comes with a 10
core M2 Graphics chip compared to eight
so we have more cores there but let's
see how much of a difference that makes
in terms of performance and we have a
score of 45 418 for the 15 inch thirty
nine thousand three twenty six for the
13. that is a difference of 15 and a
half percent for the performance and the
crazy thing is with the 13 inch you have
to spend a hundred dollars more if you
want to get the 10 Graphics cores and
then you're only at a hundred dollar
price difference between the two now
what about gaming performance I have 3D
Marks Wildlife stream unlimited mode
starting up right now which is going to
give us the frames per second with a
completely Fair off-screen test and look
at this the difference is actually even
bigger we have 41.3 frames per second
for the 15 and 34.4 for the 13. that is
just over 20 better graphics performance
so definitely noticeable if you're going
to be doing any sort of gaming now what
I'm curious about with those two extra
Graphics cores does that mean that it's
going to throttle more if you're doing
something for a while and you'll lose
that performance well for that we have
the for real video upscaler which
actually has a test that is built into
it's going to put a stress on the GPU
let's go ahead and run that Benchmark
there and we're gonna do a combo of the
graphics and the neural engine if you're
doing some scientific stuff compute
whatever you need to do with this
performance now the test is almost done
and if you guys look right here we
actually have more throttling on the 13
inch with eight cores then on the 15
inch with 10 cores now the 15 inch
actually completed this test already and
it's our first time using this program
so the scores don't just represent
graphics performance it's a mix of
everything the time the um the neural
engine as well but it was very clear
that even with 10 cores the 15 inch
still throttled less than the 8 core so
as far as performance if you care the 15
inch is better plus you get the larger
display and the better speakers and with
that you also have to remember the
larger battery size as well Apple rates
at the same but we've seen in the past
that with a similar chip if you're using
it for regular tasks or you have that in
the power saving mode which I made a
full video on that definitely helps and
the 15 inch will get better battery life
go go ahead and click that Circle above
to subscribe let me know your thoughts
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]